but actually talking of swearing you
know you were in that film my girl I was
with with very young Macaulay Culkin and
Anna clumsky yes look how sweet so could
you swear no you couldn't no no no no no
no no you're not allowed to swear in
front of children on movie said so I had
swear jars
you know swear jars if you said the s
word you had to put in a dollar if you
said the f word you had to put in two
dollars and you know the whole crew
participated because we had kids on the
set here you two are young kids sure and
you know of course once in a blue moon
we'd all be like a bank and then we'll
be like um put money in the swear jar
and you know it all went fine we all got
very tired of it but they were cute and
nice kids and the last shot of the movie
was the scene where they run uh down the
dock and then jump into the lake and I
remember we had like safety people in
the lake and stunt people and you know
and the whole thing and cranes and
things I mean I'm telling you they jump
off a dock into water like two feet deep
big thing and towels and everybody's
like and they you know run and then they
jump into the uh thing they're fine and
then everybody's like Oh yay and
everything and now they're gonna be
finished with the movie and there they
are wrapped in their towels standing at
the edge of the dock and they go ladies
and gentlemen that is a wrap for
Macaulay Culkin and Anna klumsky and
everybody goes like this and I took the
two cans and I walked up to each of them
each of the cans had like 500 bucks in
it 500 pounds and I walked up to each of
the kids and I went [__] you
yeah yeah
[Music]